when you're doing this all this acting
stuff and you're climbing up the ranks
and you're doing your this is your brain
this is your brain on drugs that was you
it wasn't that was you no I'm just the
voice oh the voice the voice yeah I
wouldn't be the on camera but
you know and you're coming up and you're
doing all this acting were there any
were you ever do you remember being
nervous or I can't do it or anxious or
just were you just confident because you
didn't know better
um
funny just side story about that actual
ad I remember like auditioning like is
very scary to me like like all of us
because we're human beings but that
audition was actually not scary to be
because I was like no way I'm getting
this because in the waiting room there's
just literally like 16 models they're
like five ten like beautiful wafey
Calvin Klein types I was like are you
serious like what am I in the
wrong room and so I was like this isn't
gonna happen so I I wasn't actually
scared because you said what do I have
to lose am I gonna get it yeah that is
always
the key interesting if you don't give a
budget I mean you'd like it well
it's also possible that they're just
actual models have never acted before
true but when you have that confidence
where you're like going in there and you
don't care yeah and those nerves that
hinder you from being your best yeah
don't come out
and you could let it all out
that's a rare thing how often does that
happen to you very little what about you
it doesn't happen a lot but what I have
those days where I'm like I belong here
and I have those days where I'm like I
don't belong to that you know what I
mean I do I do if I like
if if the room is warm and if people are
like really welcoming and the material
is good like a lot is possible